hey guys it is top five time which means
I get to tell you five massive things
that happened in gaming this week well
I've got four massive things and one
story involving ice cream but trust me
it's worth
it Sony's game streaming service
PlayStation now could be set to get a
whole lot better with the inclusion of
PS1 PS2 and PS4 titles although VP of
Sony network entertainment Eric lmy has
said that the beta is going tremendously
well on the PS4 so far Gamers have been
skeptical due to the fact that it only
offers PS3 games and the rental prices
can get as high as
$49.99 for a rental game yeah limpia
suggested that alongside the good chance
they'll start including games from other
PlayStation platforms we could also see
the controversial pricing models altered
the service is also now in open beta on
the PS3 as well as the PS4 and the 150
odd PlayStation now titles are
integrated into the PlayStation
Store Destiny's first raid launched this
week and one clever fire team defeated
it in just under 11 hours the six player
raid called Vault of Glass was described
by Bungie as their most elaborate
Mission ever created for any Destiny
fans eyeing off the raid you will have
to be level 26 to access it and be sure
to bring along five friends with you
since it doesn't support matchmaking
Prime guard wrapped up the raid in 10
hours and 40 minutes and must have done
a damn good job as bungee have said that
Vault of Glass offers up a considerable
challenge this week Microsoft bought
Minecraft creator Mojang for $2.5
billion and that's pretty much all
anybody's been talking about so here's
the lowdown the rid acquisition went
through as predicted and while fans
puzzled over why Mojang would make the
switch from being happily independent to
accepting a buyout Minecraft creator
Notch cleared some things things up in a
lengthy blog post he explained that he
wanted to create small Indie projects
and wasn't prepared for what Minecraft
became he said he didn't want to be a
symbol or an entrepreneur and after
Minecraft's huge success selling off the
company made sense for
him GTA 5 for PC was officially delayed
over the last week and Rockstar have
come out to explain why Rockstar says
they're super glad that everyone is so
Keen to play the game on PC but in their
words the game requires a little more
development time in order to ensure that
it is as amazing and Polished as
possible the PC version is now due on
January 27 while the versions for Xbox
One and PS4 are going to land on
November
18 okay dudes it's ice cream story time
and how exactly can you get your hands
on some well it's by trading in your
violent games at California's Marin
County the Marin County Independent
Journal has reported that next month you
can take your e evil toy guns and
violent video games and trade them in
for sweet sweet Ben and Jerry's ice
cream the program is being run by
district attorney Ed Barbarian who ran a
similar buyback program trading real
guns for actual money last year the ice
cream offer is on the table every
Saturday in October and the last one was
pretty successful so you might want to
round up any violent stuff you don't
want before all the ice cream gets
scooped up or the deal runs cold or a
different ice cream BU as we question of
the day let me know which of your
violent games you would trade for ice
cream or if no amount of ice cream could
make you part with your games not even
chocolate chip cookie dough which is the
best one this week on site check out
three great Kickstarter games you can
play right now on the gist we tuck into
paper bound on the lobby and alien
isolation scares the crap out of Danny
and Brian that is it for me this week as
always have yourself a wonderful weekend
and I will catch you again on
Monday